y es el momento de hablar de salud con
mi compañera Mara Romero salamares Un
saludo para usted Buenos días Ángela
empezamos con una nueva alerta sanitaria
en Europa esta vez por botulismo si
empezamos explicando que se trata de una
intoxicación por una bacteria
normalmente sucede por ejemplo con
comida mal envasada Aunque hay varios
casos que pueden originar el botulismo
esta toxina afecta a los nervios la
parálisis y provoca parálisis o
dificultad para respirar en el último
informe epidemiológico de los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades
europeos registraron 14 casos en
Alemania
12-1 en Australia Perdón 12 en Alemania
uno en Austria y uno en Suiza ahora sí
todos los pacientes habían ido a
someterse a un procedimiento en a
Turquía en Estambul que consiste en
inyectar botox en el estómago como un
procedimiento para perder peso
casualmente o precisamente la bacteria
que provoca la toxina del botox es la
misma que provoca esta enfermedad si se
administra mal no se usa normalmente en
pequeñas paraliza los músculos como
sabemos en pequeñas cantidades pero si
se administra incorrectamente puede
llegar a generar este botulismo que en
este caso se llama botulismo y
atrogénico bueno Cuál es el origen
concreto de este brote es una noticia
bien preocupante la verdad sí es
preocupante porque nos habla también de
los riesgos Al final a los que podemos
estar sometidos cuando hay
procedimientos utilizando este tipo de
sustancias parecen estar todos
conectados alrededor de una sola clínica
en Estambul y el cdc europeo los centros
de control y prevención de enfermedades
recordaron además que entre mayo y junio
del año pasado se habían reportado lotes
de botox en mal estado o falsificados en
varios países Jordania Turquía Reino
Unido Polonia y Kuwait también recordó
que se ha dado en el pasado casos de
este bulturismo y atrogénico vinculados
a un botox sin licencia o en mal estado
ya en Egipto o en Turquía aunque no se
sabe con certeza tampoco si los lotes de
estos que estaban en mal estado de 2022
están directamente relacionados con los
con el brote que existe ahora pero pues
da pistas sobre lo que hubiera podido
suceder parece que todos los pacientes
contactaron independientemente con estas
clínicas con esta clínica particular
sobre todo a través de WhatsApp para
someterse a un procedimiento de
inyección gástrica de botox es decir
inyectar botox en el estómago después de
realizarse el procedimiento requirieron
hospitalización varios de ellos algunos
incluso debieron ingresar en la UCI
porque los síntomas de botulismo son
pues tener visión borrosa vértigos
incluso de su dificultad para hablar
respirar o tragar no al final Como
decíamos el botox lo que hace es
paralizar los músculos en a gran escala
o de forma descontrolada con una
infección intoxicación de esta bacteria
se genera esta paralización de músculos
digamos de una forma más a gran escala
el procedimiento de inyección gástrica
de botox ha ganado popularidad como una
forma de perder peso y de ahí podríamos
ver pues estos casos mar y lo grave que
es afectar los procesos naturales de
nuestro Sí por supuesto No al final
estamos viendo que es un ejemplo más de
los que hemos hablado muchas veces de
también en este espacio de salud de
intentar priorizar adelgazar por delante
de cualquier cosa en este caso la base
es que el botox paraliza los músculos
del estómago para que funcionen más
lentamente Entonces se absorba más
lentamente la comida y pues se genera
una sensación de saciedad más larga
perdamos apetito y Consecuentemente haya
una pérdida de peso repasamos las cifras
de un estudio de revista en practice
realizado de hecho por investigadores
también turcos con una muestra de unos
50 pacientes vemos que el peso de media
antes del procedimiento era de 85 kilos
aproximadamente y después del
procedimiento se llegaron a los 77 kilos
casi 77 kilos de media Es decir había
unos 7 kilos de pérdida de media también
en un tiempo medio de unos dos meses
Aunque podría tomar menos o más tiempo
sin embargo también importante decir que
estos estudios no hay ninguno de hecho a
largo plazo las muestras todavía son
pequeñas entonces toca [__] con pinzas
todos estos resultados No pues más por
lo que usted nos está contando Cuáles
son los riesgos de este procedimiento
Pues en general desde las clínicas que
los practican dicen que son pues una
intervención mínima que no tiene mucho
riesgos nosotros revisamos las páginas
web de algunas de estas clínicas que
ofrecen estos servicios en Turquía por
unos 1000 euros mucho más barato que en
otros lugares dicen de nuevo no que es
un procedimiento muy seguro Aunque vemos
que el actual brote muestra que No
necesariamente tiene que ser así se
muestran o fotos también de las personas
que se han sometido a la inyección y sus
mejoras dicen que el procedimiento es
facilísimo indicado para todo el mundo y
hasta indican no como qué vuelos tomar
desde otros lugares del mundo a Turquía
para acudir a hacerse este tipo de
intervenciones aquí es importante
recordar que este efecto es temporal
después de seis meses deja de funcionar
entonces hay muchas posibilidades de
volver a ganar el peso original que se
tenía después de la intervención Y eso
como hemos dicho También muchas veces es
una puerta pues totalmente abierta los
trastornos de conducta alimentaria y el
efecto rebote de peso que tiene unos
efectos muy nocivos para la salud
probablemente mucho más nocivos que el
peso original que se tenía en la persona
no es un ejemplo más al final de
presiones estéticas a veces escondidos
también detrás de esos motivos de salud
No Y cómo Pues muchas veces acudimos a
soluciones promesas milagrosas Que sin
importar No todo lo que nos llevemos por
delante todo lo que de más le afectamos
en nuestro cuerpo que también es
importante para una salud global no para
todos nosotros y para nosotros en un
sentido completo No pues es que estamos
enfermos de gordofobia gracias a usted y
pues nos vemos mañana gracias Ángela
esta mañana